My feet began to sweat as those two fluffy little bunnies with the blue
button eyes stared sappily up at me.
Here are some things you should know about "A Christmas Story" that will change the
way you watch it forever.
Which is significant if you're like me, and plan on re watching this movie
every year, multiple times, forever.
The screenplay is based on the semi-autobiographical stories of Gene Shephard
which were originally published in the nineteen sixties for Playboy Magazine.
Gene Shepherd is also the narrator of the film and makes a cameo appearance, here,
"The line ends here, it begins there!"
By the way Peter Billingsly who plays Ralphie kept laughing during the filming of the scene
because this little girl was actually terrified of the witch.
Shepherd actually grew up on Cleveland Street in Hammond, Indiana
but the house used in filming is in Cleveland, Ohio and is now a museum
devoted to the film.
The grand prize leg lamp is based on the NEHI Cola logo.
The brand used an exposed leg in stockings to indicate the correct pronunciation of "NEHI"
Jack Nicholson was considered for the role the old man,
but is fee would have doubled the budget of the film.
Also Darren McGavin couldn't be more perfect.
"Fra-gee-lay, it must be Italian!"
A suction tube is hidden in this poll, which makes for the convincing sticking effect.
Scott Schwartz who played Flick went on to appear in a number of adult films in the 1990s
Farkis is actually Hungarian for "wolf" and the music we hear when he enters is
the theme from Prokofiev's "Peter and the Wolf."
All of Ralphie's nonsensical cursing the scene was scripted word-for-word.
"Holyy smokes!"
This kid in goggles was not an actor, but
just happened to be in a department store during filming.
The director Bob Clark, who makes a cameo here,
thought he was appropriately weird and decided to put him in this scene.
"What I want for christmas is a Red Rider BB-gun with a compass on the stock and this thing which tells time."
"The thing which tells time" is an engraved sundial
Daisy never actually made a Red Rider rifle that fits the specifications,
however they did make a more expensive Buck Jones rifle which did.
In case you've never noticed Bo Ling's Chop Suey is using a bowling sign here
with the W darked out.
the actors were not told about the singing waiters prior to
the filming of this scene
and Melinda Dillons who plays the mother is actually hysterically laughing here.
Ralphie states that he wants a Red Ryder BB gun
twenty-eight times throughout the course the film. ]
Now think about how many times you've seen this movie,
and marvel at the fact that it never gets old.
Oh my god I shot my eye out! You'll shoot your eye out kid. You'll shoot your eye out! Hoooo Hoooooooo Hoooooooo.